i would like to set the story straight
gentlemen um go on
all the comments clowned on me said that
i broke two cars and we have a guest
here
who's an expert and he actually you know
the guy right there what was his name
because we didn't actually get it oh you
didn't actually um okay so the guy that
took you for a ride
right right the big orange car with the
carbon fiber helmet the driving
the drip well his name is
and he's one of the two members of well
one of many a few members of team orange
which is
why the car was orange right right team
orange is the
team which is based at msu circuit the
leader of the team
is also the manager of the circuit as
well right and now tsunaga is one of the
drivers uh for competition and also
another guy who drives
with him as well and they're both doing
i think the two team orange drivers one
of them is currently in first place
in the the national drifting competition
and i think sooner is about fifth
so you what you're with one of the best
drivers yeah because arguably in the
world yeah because i remember we got
a lot of comments on that video being
like did they not realize who the drift
killed actually
it was two comments it was like do they
not realize the cars that you're
drifting in as well
which were apparently some very special
cars i like we knew nothing going into
this
i'll get the one with the spoiler all
the car enthusiasts like
the so the guy anyway so the guy you got
uh nalto uh
he's a really cool guy like you noticed
that he was like laughing and smiling
yeah yeah
he's actually like that all the time
like he's whenever yeah yeah
he's actually uh one of the videos on my
channel uh it's called a high-speed
violent drift which is which is based
around entirely his driving
i mean that's the best way to explain
what we wear he's very he's very quick
he's very
good like the way it's like watching
bruce lee like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was not and you told me that he
you were texting him right
because i just just before yeah right
right right and you asked him what i'd
done to the cars
yeah do you want to explain to the
audience so i can be uh
cleansed of my sins indicative of okay
so breaking a car
in drifting is not uncommon it's
obviously that's what i figured right
yeah
it feels like it felt pretty easy to
[ __ ] up a car yeah yeah you know
doing what you do in a drift car is
almost the exact opposite of what people
tell you to do to a car to begin with
yeah and i think what happened with you
was with the first car which was uh
an r33 skyline is that special uh it's
well i mean look okay all the cars that
you drove are not available
uh in any other country apart from japan
like originally being sold because yeah
i saw a lot of comments that were they
were jealous that we
were able to drive these cars and i like
i didn't know what was so special about
them
well the skyline i mean people know the
skyline the skyline gtl it's like sort
of the apex
you know japanese sports car that people
want to get uh so there's that
you didn't have the gta you had the gtst
it's like one step down but it's
rear-wheel drive that's right
uh the other cars that you drove were a
um they were both
uh jcx 90 mark ii and jsx 100 mark
ii right and
it's okay sorry some people people know
what i'm talking about so
the the what makes those cars special is
uh the fact that they're turbo rear
wheel drive
they suit which means the rear wheels
spin instead of the front wheels
it's good for drifting and what uh those
cars become very popular recently
especially overseas because like i said
they weren't sold overseas
but in countries like america they can
import cars that are up to
over 25 years old right right and those
guys are just coming up to 25 years old
now
so everyone's like oh i want to get one
of these because you know
you notice that the toyotas were the
last to break right
the nissan broke first toyota's uh you
know anyone who's driven a
a camry or anything like that will know
like they just last forever
yeah so they're they're popular uh
people are looking forward to getting
them so that's
why people were hyped i actually drive
one the same as the the who drove the
white car that was you i got i drove
my wolf car is the same as that the one
that didn't break yeah the one that was
the one the only one that lasted what
was the diagnosis
to the cars that i drove so naga said
that you
probably broke a coil pack okay which is
uh it's like part of the electronics on
this which is why they said battery
right
oh it's part of the the electronics it
sits on the engine and makes the spark
that burns the fuel yeah
right right so normally when you drive a
car you're driving forward and you're
not doing burnouts and spinning the
wheels
yeah stopping making a lot of heat and
stuff like that so that day was very hot
yeah you probably overheated the coil
pack so it sits on top of the engine
which is hot
and okay obviously i'm liking the sound
i thought i [ __ ] the clutch or
something but i don't know if that's it
sounded like it
it made like the worst sound i'd ever
heard it was like
i mean they those cars make weird noises
like honestly like if you the first time
if you drive like if i jump in someone
else's drift car and like just even
drive it around
yeah uh you have to spend the first five
minutes going okay that's a normal noise
usually the way it works is if if
something smells different or sounds
dramatically different
then you probably have a problem after
that because because
i remember when we first got into the
cars for the first time i mean they were
stripped bear i'd never been in a car
like that that was just
specifically designed for one purpose
and that was for drifting you know
and it was it felt like when i was
turning on the engine it was like
coughing i was like
and i was like is this normal but it
sounded like and it felt like these cars
had been
gone through a hell of a beating which
is what they kind of they asked them
for the school uh for the team orange
school which is what you did
um i've actually in the in the past
being an assistant teacher like a
translator for uh
like the yeah in english for the like
the highest some of the higher level oh
yeah
it was a while ago yeah like we had a
guy who was like um uh
investment banker for barclays bank or
something like that
you know he had like uh he had ferraris
back home in england and before he was
being sent back home
you know back to his home office from
japan yeah uh
he'd been asked by his secretary is
there anything he'd like to do
you know before you know with something
we'd like to do oh i'd like to try
drifting so they set all this up and
they
you know they sent him there on the
train
yeah i was like oh this is like super
high level guests and and he thoroughly
enjoyed it so
we have all sorts of people and so those
cars have been through a lot of
i i figured that those cars were they
were a car
but i i just assumed they were all bits
and pieces that have been repaired and
repaired and repaired right like
can you even call it the car at that
point right isn't that like a philosophy
question where it's like if you're
the farmer's axe or yeah ship of theseus
yeah yeah
a lot of them are like i mean i i've
seen what at least the skyline i've seen
it personally go through two clutches
before so
i mean when they even opened the thing
all of the parts looked like
like completely different ages like you
it looked like a tight line
it looked like it looked like you know
like a lego like thing
that your five-year-old makes out of the
bucket of legos when none of the pieces
fit together it's like
i mean it's it's it's a piece of work i
guess yeah the
i mean those cars are all unfortunately
all the best drift cars are starting to
get quite old like
like 20 30 years ago and uh you know you
have to
start taking you know you'll have like
some people will buy if they have space
you'll buy like two or three of these
cars you have them at the back
something breaks you take a part or you
smash it you cut off the metal and weld
it onto the
car and fix it so yeah they're all like
that it's it's uh it's unique you can't
you can't love a drift car you can love
like the
it can have like it it's just kind of
esoteric but a drift car will have its
own
spirit right but it's not related to the
body of the car it's
the ghost of the drift yeah it's it's
you might have to change the engine you
have to change this
chase yeah that's basically all parts
getting changed yeah so that's one car
that i [ __ ] but it wasn't my fault in
the end thank you
yeah we should second card what was the
second card
he didn't get back to me about that i
don't know so you probably did [ __ ] back
up
but you gave me a theory off the podcast
saying that he reckons it's all the
stalling that somebody did to it that
might have [ __ ] it
so on uh please tell please tell i'm
pleased i think of you
i'm assuming that you didn't you edited
it out like most of the stalling you did
it's like there's a lot more than what
actually
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i stole the
video but that was probably maybe like a
third of the amount that i mean
we could probably make a like an hour
special just on or just just on joey's
stalling
by himself but it's probably to explain
to our audio only listeners that
probably didn't see the drifting video
so we made
a drift special where you should
definitely go watch get off get off
whatever platform you are go go on
youtube get on youtube
um and yeah we made a drift special
where we
tried to learn drifting for the first
time
ever basically this is our first
underlying bold letters
yeah right and uh i didn't break two
cards
you absolutely broke two cards but but i
guess for like for our listeners who
know nothing about drifting no nothing
about car culture do you want to explain
like what drift culture is
especially in japan from like in like
layman's terms
okay well drifting is uh if you've never
done it before
is uh like most people who have driven a
car well these days like cars have a lot
of safety features on them like
they have anti-lock brakes and stability
control and all this sort of stuff which
sort of
you know protects you a little bit from
making too much of a mistake right yeah
but
everybody who has lived somewhere it
rains a lot or it snows or something
like that
has had a moment where you've gone
around a corner or like a roundabout or
something
where the car is just sort of going like
this yeah or like that you're like
yeah you get that crunch in your stomach
you're like oh that's not right
yeah that's the feeling we're going for
the whole
the the the feeling of like the out of i
mean i think they said that
in um tokyo drive it's like you got to
be out of control to be in control
it's that it's that it's that feeling of
of
being on the edge it's it's like you
know surfing or skiing it's like you're
not you're not gripping what you're on
you're sliding across it
and it's that being on the razor edge of
that of that slide which is just so much
fun
not everybody thinks it's fun some
people do i mean the same thing like i
mean some people
love surfing some people love skiing or
ice skating or whatever any of those
sorts of things where it's like
something
like that you know you can enjoy it like
that's not for me but then some people
just get a massive
rush yeah it was it was a lot of fun i
remember
experiencing the drift taxi for the
first time i remember having the
conversation
with joey which we didn't record but
joey was telling me how it felt like
the afterglow after sex is what you
described as
like i was metaphorically rock-hard like
i was like damn dude
i was like damn how am i ever going to
get an erection again
some of the most in i mean some of the
most chill i've ever been in my life was
you know driving back from a track day
yeah which was so nice
like yeah nine o'clock at night on the
expressway just cruising along going
back home it's like you know cool breeze
and it's just like
you get a every every every single you
know organ in your body which can
release some sort of chemical
enjoyment chemical yeah it does that it
honestly does that like i've had times
where like when i up when i first moved
here and i remember i bought the car i
did this stuff
finally got to track day and this one
particular corner i hit it it was a big
long third geek corner and i literally
yelled out
this is why i came to japan
it was that feeling it was like i was
looking for that like yeah he found his
life purpose going around the corner
yeah it's just really enjoyable